foreign
[Music]
for The Kino check news here we go Doom
3 is set to shatter the heroic image of
its main character Henry Cavill will be
the new Highlander and Leonardo Dicaprio
and Martin Scorsese have their next
project in mind after killers of the
flower Moon there is also news about the
theatrical release of Godzilla X Kong as
well as the new the Lord of the Rings
film
the cult game finally on the big screen
in the second trailer for The Five
Nights at Freddy's movie there are also
plenty of references to the original
game about Freddy and his buddies fans
can look forward to some murderous fun
Five Nights at Freddy's is based on the
horror game series of the same name and
tells us the story of Mike Schmidt who
was hired as a night security guard in a
rundown Diner however when he learns
that the animatronic puppets are
inhabited by The Souls of dead children
he has to fear for his life the first
trailer already caused a lot of
excitement the audience particularly
enjoyed the wealth of detail the new
trailer likewise shows that the movie
will remain true to the original first
there's the familiar view of the
surveillance camera monitors then there
are some unwelcome guests in Freddy's
pizzeria who have to deal directly with
the terrifying animatronics after the
introduction of security guard Mike
played by Josh Hutcherson we finally get
to meet the bad guys foxy Bonnie Chica
and Freddy then Mike pretty much sums up
the story ghost children possessing
giant robots the trailer ends with a
surprise guest of course fan favorite
springtrap also makes an appearance in
the film even after this trailer the big
question remains as to how explicit the
film will be in terms of violence and
most importantly what rating the film
will end up with well actually the film
has been given a PG-13 rating in the U.S
due to the violent nature of the film
bloody images and harsh language the
Five Nights at Freddy movie movements in
theaters on October 27th and is sure to
cause some excitement among the large
fan community
it has to be expected the postponement
of Doom 2 sets off a chain reaction of
further delays on the part of Warner
thus Godzilla x-con the new Empire and
the Lord of the Rings The War of the
rohiram are also receiving new release
dates the postponement of Dune 2 to
mid-march is causing a real knockout
effect the monster Blockbuster Godzilla
x-con for example has been pushed back
from March 15th to April 12 2024 and the
new the Lord of the Rings animated film
is even being significantly delayed it
will not be released for another six
months on December 13 2024 due to the
current writers and actor strike many
Productions are at a standstill me that
shootings for films such as Gladiator 2
Beetlejuice 2 mission impossible 8 or
the new Tarantino film the movie critic
are likely to be delayed further putting
any planned release dates at risk at
least two big Warner films are set to be
released this year a scheduled Waka
starring Timothy chalamet will keep its
December 15th release date and Jason
Momoa is still expected to bring the
movie year to a dramatic Clues with
Aquaman 2 on December 20th
although Dune 2 has been officially
pushed back to next year due to the
strikes director Dennis milnev has
expressed his enthusiasm for a third
installment the initial idea was to
adapt the famous novel by Frank Herbert
into two films thanks to the success and
Global popularity of Dune the director
was able to realize his plan Doom 2
which Villeneuve describes as an
action-packed in Epic War film is
scheduled for release on March 15
2024. part 2 was supposed to be the end
of the story but there's still room for
more fans of the original know of course
that the film adaptations are merely
adaptations of the first novel however
the literary work of arrakis includes
several other books that also provide
material for potential future film
adaptations this opinion is likewise
shared by Dennis villenev who talked
about a possible third part in an
interview with Empire it is to be based
on the second novel Dune Messiah it
shows that Paul is anything but a hero
even if many perceive him that way it
was villenev's dream to tell the story
Trilogy the other Dune books however
would be too esoteric form whether a
third movie will actually be made in the
end remains to be seen and is also
likely to depend on the success of its
predecessor Doom was successful in 2021
but not to the extent that mourner would
have liked however we can't expect that
part 2 won't be a flop either after all
the anticipation for the upcoming film
seems way too huge so there's a good
chance that villanov will be able to
realize his visions and present us with
an epic conclusion to the story of
arrakis with June 3. there seems to be
no lack of ideas and enjoyment of the
story material
from The Witcher to the Highlander after
Christopher Lambert Henry Cavill is now
to take on the role of the immortal
swordsman John Wick director Chad
stachowski gave an interview about the
current status of the project plans for
a reboot of the 1986 fantasy classic
Highlander have been in the pipeline
since 2016. the movie is about a group
of chosen Immortals who fight each other
over the course of centuries until there
is only one remaining The Immortals
motto there can be only one since the
announcement of the reboot the project
has been joined by some great names
director stahlski is considered an
absolute connoisseur of the action genre
and the John Wick movies speak for
themselves then two years ago it was
revealed that Henry Cavill had been cast
in the role of the Highlander in the
happy sad confused podcast stahelski now
gave an update on the project and
reported why a return of the Highlander
is currently taking such a long time
according to him the entire project
revolves a lot around the same
characters as in the previous movies and
TV series but at the same time time it
is also kind of a prequel and prepares
the final Gathering of the Immortals
mortal they want to take as much time as
possible to do justice to the complex
story it won't be a simple remake of the
original but rather the starting point
for further movies from the universe
currently everything is still in the
planning phase and therefore it is hard
to tell when the adventure will be shown
on the big screen what is certain
however is that with stahlski and Cabell
very talented people are in charge of
the project
news from Hollywood's Dream Team another
collaboration between Star director
Martin Scorsese and actor Leonardo
DiCaprio is on the way the wager is set
to be another novel adaptation by author
David Gran after killers of the flower
Moon and will tell a story between
heroism and Mutiny The Wager with the
subtitle a tale of shipwreck Mutiny and
murder is based on true events and
recounts the story of a group of men who
are washed ashore on the coast of Brazil
they report that they are the sole
survivors of the British ship wager
Shipwrecked on a deserted island after
fighting a Spanish Galleon the members
of the group are initially celebrated as
Heroes however some six months later
other men arrive who accuse them of
mutiny and approach them for leaving the
rest of the crew for death the movie is
to take place in three locations at sea
the island and in a courtroom
Leonardo DiCaprio will once again play a
leading role more specific details
though are not available yet it also
remains to be seen whether the wager
will really be scorsese's next project
the director has plenty of other
projects up his sleeve including a movie
about Jesus a biopic about former U.S
president Theodore Roosevelt also
featuring DiCaprio and a project about
the band Grateful Dead in which Jonah
Hill is to play the role of frontman
Jerry Garcia he'll already collaborated
with Scorsese in The Wolf of Wall Street
it therefore remains to be seen which
project the director will tackle next
The Wager is nonetheless considered a
hot contender
that wraps things up for today are you
excited for Five Nights at Freddy's we
sure are and just in case you want to
see more content check out our movie
preview for I am Legend 2 starring Will
Smith and Michael B Jordan thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
Keno check news
[Music]
oh